[Techno theme music]
- Welcome to ear biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm link.
This week at the round table of
dim lighting we're gonna ask the
question, how do we party?
- How do we party, man?
- And we're gonna answer
that question for you.
- And specifically, what we mean by that,
because, it was--
- How do you party, bro?
- It wasn't intended to be a little bit,
you know, clickbaity
because I mean, who are we
trying to kid here?
We wanted you to click.
Those of you that need
that kind of motivation.
We're talking about, specifically is,
the way that we approach
the Hollywood indus-,
industry.
- Industry.
- Industry party scene, which we have
become somewhat familiar with this year.
- We're starting, well,
we're starting to become
familiar with it.
The one party that I
think we're gonna spend
a lot of time on was...
It was...
- The GQ party.
- Late, that was late last year.
- Yeah.
- It was not this year, technically.
So yeah, there was that party,
there was a golden
clothes, we just haven't
had an opportunity to like, fully process
with you, our experience of these parties.
And it is a whole world in and of itself.
Not just the party but the, I mean,
this whole aspect of the industry.
- Well--
- It's a part of it, so, you know,
the goal of this episode is just to...
Share with you our
experience, warts and all.
I don't think there'll be that many warts.
Yes there are.
- I just want to have fun talking about it
because it's some of the
more hilarious things
that have happened, in your presence,
have happened at these parties.
- I don't know.
- And uh--
- I don't know if I'm
if I'm fully ready to--
- Well, I'm ready.
- The world.
- You can watch me tell 'em.
- Know about it.
But I trust you, uh ear biscuiteer, with--
- But don't trust me.
- With--
- We trust that you will keep all of this
in confidence.
- With my experience, yeah because it's...
- We also, we did share
that one story about
the party we were at where
we couldn't get a drink--
- Yeah, at the bar.
- At the bar.
And then, you know, that was on
a previous podcast.
I don't know which one it was.
- I think that guy's still thinking about
probably not making us a drink--
- And that is just kind of like a small
indication of what our
subsequent experiences have been.
Now, I'm gonna start with
what I think is a maxim,
a thesis of what--
- Okay.
- Of why--
- Course she could just say it's
a hypothesis but--
- No, no, it's not--
- I mean, you could go all the way.
- No, it's not hypothesis.
it is a maxim, from which, or a principle,
from which, all of the stuff, in all of
the reasons that we're gonna talk about
why we even do this.
- Yeah.
- Why it exists.
And that is because...
I'm gonna try to make
it sound like a maximum.
That--
- A maximum.
- A maximum maxim, that
which fuels Hollywood
is bull.
- Yeah.
- That is the maximum.
Okay?
- Yeah.
- And what I mean by
that is that, if you talk
about the Hollywood machine, now let's say
the Hollywood machine is
a vehicle and you were
to look into the gas
tank and you were like,
what fuels this Hollywood machine?
And I, and the premise is, you open up
the gas cam and it's full of bull.
Or I would say, it might be
a vapid tank of emptiness.
- Well, no I think that's the destination.
That's--
- That is what your soul becomes.
- But that is the
destination of the Hollywood
machine, is a vast tank
of emptiness, but the fuel
is both, and here's what I'm saying,
is that, every single, you
know, you want to believe.
You want to believe that
all this is based on
art and talent and obviously
those things exist.
You need to be good at what you're doing
to kind of get into, to
some extent, to kind of
get into the game at all.
- And then you might
add to that, okay yeah,
it's also who you know.
- But--
- Because we're all humans and--
- But that's--
- You might be thinking that.
- That's part of bull.
- I think it goes further because that--
- I'm including that.
- Knowing people and
like getting things done
with people that you know
or that you know someone
who knows someone, and you feel like
there's a little bit
more trust or there's...
Something, like I owe this person.
That's true of just
life, in a lot of ways.
So I think that what you're getting at
goes even further than that, to this,
just, you want to start
to think that like,
oh there's people in
Hollywood and they're going
to parties and they're
all having a great time
and just hanging out and...
The people who are at parties are popular.
So if you are seen at a party, then you
are seen as popular, as
hot as as the cool crowd.
I mean, it's like,
there's this, high school
cool crowd thing that
happens and it's a whole game
built around...
Like the whole TMZ pictures being taken,
voyeuristic Entertainment
Tonight type situation.
- Well, it's all about perception.
And the reality is
superseded by the perception
and the perception determines the reality
in a lot of ways.
- Yes.
- In this town.
Right?
Now, and let me say that,
I'm not critiquing that.
This podcast is not about critiquing that.
Obviously it has been well critiqued
and I think that we navigate
the space, knowing...
at least being somewhat
familiar with the pitfalls
of like, thinking that this is where
ultimate purpose belongs, we don't...
That's not what we
believe and so, we kind of
play this game, trying
to figure out the rules
but knowing that the
vast tank of emptiness
at the end of the rainbow is not something
that we're interested in.
But what we are interested
in, is we're interested in
exercising our craft, right?
That's what we're trying to do.
And we want to do that
on the most significant
level possible and, so
that's kind of our purpose
in what we do and why
we're playing this game.
We play the game because
we want to continue
to create and we want to be able to create
in the most significant way.
And the best and most
strategic way to do that,
for us, is to do it in
the context of the system,
at least somewhat.
We obviously--
- 'Cause now we're doing a lot, that we're
very proud of and that
we're very glad to continue
to be doing in this alternate reality
that came from the internet.
- Right.
- And, you know, so without sacrificing
any of that, you know, we still want to
make a movie.
We still want to make
another scripted story,
a scripted series that
is seen by more people
than Buddy System season
two, to date, has been
seen by.
So--
- Right.
- We start to say, do we
need to start putting,
you know, getting in the ring and playing
this game?
- Well, let me--
- We need to buy a ticket
to the game and start
playing it.
- Well, let me just address--
- To get some opportunity.
- Address one criticism
which I relate to and
appreciate, because
there's a lot of people
who make digital content
like us and independent
creators who make digital
content, you know,
everything we do on YouTube, this podcast,
all the stuff that we do independently,
we can cancel ourselves.
We determine when the
season starts and ends.
That's completely outside
of the Hollywood machine
in a lot of ways, right?
So you might say, well why
don't you just continue
to create in that sphere?
You guys could just make a movie.
You guys could go on
Kickstarter and raise money
from Mythical Beasts
and just make a movie.
Yes that is a path, and we're not saying
we'll never do that, but, in the current
situation that we find
ourselves in, the most...
Yeah, you can put that on airplane mode,
because, you know, we might as well be on
an airplane, right now.
The way to get your work to be considered
by the people who kind of control
the cultural conversation is,
you know, it's very,
very difficult, to say,
make a movie completely outside the system
and just sell it directly
to people who already
know you and for that
to be as significant,
and I don't know, maybe we'll learn,
X number of years down the road that,
we should just not even pursued this,
but for better or worse,
what we are pursuing
right now, is trying to
create things on a higher
level and do it with at
least a portion of what
we're doing as part of our
career, within the system.
- Mm-hmm.
- So...
- And, so you hire a PR firm to help you
navigate and give to you
opportunities and get
you into stuff.
- Right.
- So we're doing that.
And that's how you get into these parties
before you become like, a bigger star,
in their eyes.
- Before--
- In the people who are
throwing the parties eyes.
- Before the people throwing
the parties want you
to be at the parties.
Which was not where we're
at right now, right?
- Right.
- You have to find
somebody who can get you
into the parties.
- Right.
- It's, again, bull--
- And that's not--
- Right?
- Feel's a little dirty when it's like,
you know we're saying that involves money.
- But the funny--
- I mean I'm just--
- Well, yeah, when you get--
- Indirectly, but yeah.
- Yeah but, the interesting thing, just to
give you a small example of this.
So the structure of a lot of these parties
is that you show up at
the event and there is
a red carpet.
You get your picture taken by a series
of photographers, you've seen these.
We share those photos and we try to do our
little stance, the
handshake stance and stuff
like that but, one of the things I noticed
pretty early on, is that, we went to a few
of these parties last year and...
It's all the same photographers.
I mean, there's a relatively small pool
of people, right?
And so it's just like
like you can hear them,
they're like, who are these guys?
And then we have to say,
it's rhett and Link and--
- No last names.
- What are your last names?
Well, don't worry about our last names.
Could you stand on that side?
No, we stand like this.
We stand like rhett and Link.
Like there was a lot of orientation
for people to understand what we were
trying to do.
And then, little by
little, you start hearing
people say, I actually
heard a photographer
say, "oh it's those guys again."
And it's--
- Oh, it's working.
- Sadly--
- Somebody's bored of us already.
- Sadly, oh it's those guys again,
is what we're looking for, right?
So, the people who--
- I bet ya they're gonna shake hands
and then raise their, one of their legs.
- There they go, they're doing that
dumb pose again.
So--
- And why?
- That is part of it.
I'm just saying that that is part of the--
- It's one of the biggest
parts of the game.
- System.
- Before you even get into the party,
you got to do this and, matter of fact,
you could just stop there.
Because it's such an
important part of the party,
you could make an argument, and I think
many celebrities do, in their own mind.
They show up for the red carpet, and then
they just leave and don't
even go to the party
because they got their picture taken,
proof that they were
there, because the game,
or at least a big aspect of it, is--
Looking like you belong
with the cool people.
It's like, oh, this is a cool thing,
and here's a picture of that person at it.
That's it.
I can prove I'm in the group.
I'm in the group.
- Yeah.
- I got my picture in the same place
that these other, like, Jeff Goldblum
got his picture.
- Right.
- And then you go into
the party after that
and you're like, okay
yeah, like 90% of this
is done.
It's like you, because
you got your picture,
you got your credit.
- And so, the way that we approach these
parties though, and
this is what we're gonna
get into, it's not the...
Obviously we do the red carpet thing.
We get the picture.
So somebody who writes
something on the internet
will associate us with
this particular event.
But of course, we approach it, you know,
yeah, okay, we may have a
show that's very popular,
in certain circles, and
we may have some stuff
to show and some stuff to be able to say,
"hey, we should be here."
I mean, we've created this and that.
But what we're kind of,
the overarching thing
that we're thinking, when we're there,
is really the sort of,
the perspective of like,
13 year old Rhett and Link, you know?
- [Link] Yeah.
- Buies Creek Elementary School.
It's like, there's a lot
of famous people here,
who do you want to talk to?
(Rhett laughing)
You know, really.
- Right.
- Or, how good is the food?
- Where?
- Where is the food?
How much is it?
How big are the plates?
- Well, there's two things going.
There's learning the
game which is, you know,
it's a challenge, that,
in trying to figure out
how this game is played and, you know,
how do you get points, and how do you
advance your strategy
and all those things,
that's interesting.
Observing it as an outsider,
is very entertaining,
to us, I believe.
- Oh yeah.
- And hence why we're
happy to talk about it.
- Right.
- But then there's also an aspect of it
that is, you know, then you're actually,
you're trying to get to know people.
There is another part of the game that is
getting to know people that are successful
at getting things done
and making connections.
Because it is that, who
you know, and who you met,
and when you met him, and
how was their breath cuz,
do you like them?
Do you want to keep working with them?
- Or how is their breath huh?
- You know, that type of
stuff, because they're
just humans, too.
So it's humans working with humans.
So you got to work that part of it.
But then the question in my mind,
and this will become
painfully obvious once we
get into what happened
is, man, is it worth it?
It turns out there's
a lot of risk involved
in trying to play this game.
There's a risk of--
- I think there's risk
when you play the game.
- All types of emotional, if not--
- Which is--
- Physical injury, emotional injury,
embarrassment.
Man, it really does feel, a lot of times,
like it's your first day in high school
walking around the cafeteria
with your lunch tray
trying to figure out who do you sit with
or who do you sit next to
and is there gonna be an
open seat at all or am
I gonna trip and fall?
And boy the risk is real.
I'll just leave it at that
for the moment, but um--
- Yeah and hopefully--
- A little unpacking.
- Entertaining to you.
But before we get into
the stories, we do want to
let you know that you can grab...
A hat!
We got, you know, they're calling these
dad hats, it's what the youths are into
these days.
- Mm-hmm.
- We've got a tan one.
We've got a black one with
a mythical logo on it,
the Randler.
- It's nice.
- Link, the one that you have on has some,
like actual metal buttons on the side.
- This is nice workmanship.
- There's leather straps in the back.
- Yeah, so you can get that.
- Also, we are selling,
at amazon.com/mythical,
we are selling the
blu-ray, yes this is still
a thing, this is still a technology.
There are still blu-ray player--
- I'm going to call
this a collector's item,
The Tour Mythicality: Live in Los Angeles.
- Yeah, so that was when we
recorded the entire tour.
Obviously it's available,
you know, on other
platforms like iTunes, but you can get
the physical thing, the physicality of
The Tour of Mythicality.
- Yeah.
- And there's a disc inside of that,
for those of you who don't understand
what blu-ray is.
It's a disc.
You take that round thing, you insert it,
not into your mouth, but
into a blu-ray player.
And then it's a video that will play.
- It's just nice to have
even if you never watch.
- There's like a menu, and you can click
on different options.
It's very advanced.
Basically defines, you
know, our adolescent years.
Or at least--
- Amazon.com/mythical--
- Teenagers.
- And mythical.store, get it.
- Okay, so do you want to
talk about the GQ party?
- Yeah, let's talk about
them in chronological
order because I think,
there's things that we
learned that, then the
question with the Golden Globes
party is where any of
those lessons then applied.
- I think somewhere.
- I think that's one
of the main questions.
And plus I just want to get
this whole GQ experience.
I just want to cleanse it from my system.
But, so put it on the
internet, it's gonna hurt.
It might hurt a little
bit, but at least it'll be
out of me and on to you.
(Link laughing)
- Okay so I can talk a little
bit about the philosophy
of how we operate at these parties.
Okay, so.
- Well, Stevie was with us.
- So yeah, well, yeah, that's part of it.
So--
- That's the first, she was
with us for that one, anyway.
- Stevie went with us to the
GQ party, which, you know,
I think there's a different dynamic when
it's just two guys
walking around the party
like we had at the Golden Globes HBO party
then when you've got,
sort of three people,
two guys and a girl, cuz
now you kind of seem like,
this is a group and at any time that you
just begin talking to each
other, you just look like
people who are a group of people talking.
But two guys talking to each other--
- Yeah, they came together.
- Doesn't a constitute a group, really.
- [Link] Right.
- Especially when they both have on
tuxes and look, obviously your friends
in the way that we were
kind of in the (mumbles).
- [Link] Yeah.
They're not talking to anyone except who
they came with.
But with three, there's a question.
- Right.
- That's good.
- And, you know, I'm
gonna, before we expose,
Link, a little bit, I'm
going to build him up
a little bit.
Because Link, between the two of us,
is the one who is more
fearless and just beginning
to talk to somebody, right?
He's always been the one that would go up
to somebody, kind of
initiate a conversation.
I'm very standoffish
in like, self-conscious
and don't like to do that.
I don't ever talk to
celebrities when I see 'em,
even if I'm a fan.
But Link is very comfortable with that.
It leads to some great
opportunities and some
great mishaps as you will see.
- Well, it's, I mean, the whole point is
to talk to people, to get to know people
at a party.
- No. No, wait, no, it's great.
And so--
- But it is very difficult
to talk to people.
I mean--
- Yeah.
- Again, it goes back to that whole like,
you're in high school and you're like,
you don't know anybody in the cafeteria.
And you're like, to make
your way you got to start
meeting people and there
is a pecking order.
- Yeah, well--
- It's like, no but, I
mean, who's gonna come up
and talk to us?
- Right, well, and to--
- - There are exceptions.
- Kind of contrast it, and so obviously
it's one of those things
that like, this is like
life advice, right?
So, when you are with somebody who has
a particular strength, just let them
do that thing, right?
Don't, I have absolutely,
I don't care at all
that he's the one that ends...
Like if Link and I are
helping someone move,
for instance, well you
know what Links gonna do?
He's gonna be the one that
is in the moving truck
organizing and tetrasing the stuff into
the moving truck.
- Yeah and you're gonna be eating whatever
food they provide.
- Right.
Now, and I got a--
- I've got a bad back, you know.
- And so--
- Where your doughnuts?
- Not only is he good at that but he likes
to do that.
Let someone use their gifts.
So when we go to a party
together I'm like, all right.
Like when I went to the Queer
Eye for the Straight Guy
premiere party with my
wife, just the two of us.
- Yeah.
- She's a big fan of the show.
I am, sort of, a
proximate fan of the show,
through her.
- Mm-hm.
- And have watched it
with her a few times.
And we really wanted to
talk to some of the cast,
but she's just--
- You wanted to lock a queer eye.
- She's just--
- With your eye.
- She's just like me in that she doesn't,
she's just, she feels
like, I don't want to
look stupid.
I don't wanna be embarrassed.
So we ended up talking, we only talked to
people, like she saw
Nate Berkus, you know,
the designer, and she
had a point of connection
and she had something and
they've been to the same,
anyway she talked to him for
a second and that was like,
cool and that worked.
But we didn't end up actually
having a conversation
with any of the cast because at some point
they ended up just hanging out
with John Legend and Chrissy Teigen and--
- [Link] Right.
- Just in this group and it was like,
it was impenetrable.
I actually went up to the group, because
Lance Bass was on the outside of the group
and I told Jessie, I was like, I bet that
Lance Bass knows who I am.
I was going out on a limb, but I was like,
he's done a bunch of stuff with YouTubers.
- So you hovered around Lance Bass,
member of what, NSYNC?
- Is it NSYNC?
- And then waited for him to turn around--
- No, no.
- And maybe recognize--
- No, no, that's not what I did.
What I did is I was
like, I'm gonna go up to
Lance Bass and initiate a conversation.
And then I will figure out...
I will know instantly
if he knows who I am.
if he does, I'm on the
exterior of the circle
and I might be able to
do a flip or switcheroo
and suddenly be on the
inside of the circle.
- Oh, like body slam down.
- Now, you've got to
understand, this took a lot.
This took a lot for me.
I went up to Lance Bass
and I said, "hey Lance.
I'm Rhett."
And he was like, cool.
- Cool.
- Or something like that.
And continued to sort of
bob his head to the music.
- He was waiting to get
in on the other convo
and he didn't want you
to block him from it.
- Yeah, and I think I said something else,
but it was, you know I had an out plan.
I don't remember what it
was, but I took the out.
I pulled the ripcord
real soon, real early.
Total fail.
So I've been there, too, bud.
- Yeah, and we talked about this.
So then I knew going into this party,
I'm like, all right, I'm gonna...
I'm the tip of the spear, you know?
I'm gonna stab around
and then once I plunge
into some flesh then you
guys are gonna run in
and say, oh I'm sorry, this is my spear.
Let me yank that out and
let's have a conversation.
That was the stated plan.
I mean, we were all on the same page.
- The plan was that you would start
the conversation and that
we would then come in
and continue the conversation.
But the, sort of, unforeseen thing that
didn't happen is, we didn't discuss any
of the parameters for how you would begin
a conversation.
- Right.
And why would you do that?
- And that's kind of the
lessons that we ended
up learning.
- Well, like I said,
there's a pecking order.
So you go in there and I mean, it's,
you know, it's, to initiate a conversation
with somebody that is known and famous,
you are immediately...
It is a position of weakness and of,
your lower.
Because your Emmy and it's kind of like,
well, are you a fan or
are you another person
that I should think is cool?
There's some psychological
stuff happening.
- And not just that but, the percentages,
the breakdown of like,
recognizable, you know,
this sounds, again, I
said from the beginning,
the premise is that, the
fuel of the Hollywood
machine is bull, so we're going with that
for a second.
The percentage of people who are "famous",
you know, the celebrities, is a minority--
- Very low.
- Of people at this party.
The majority of people at the party are
industry people who have
a connection to the brand
or the company, the people
who are putting the party on.
And so, this isn't like,
which we've never been
to a kind of party where
like, you go to like,
a celebrity's home and
every single person there
is a celebrity.
That's a different, that's
like a private party.
We've never been invited to one of those.
- No, but--
- This is the kind of thing where,
if you're a celebrity,
you know that there's
a bunch of regular folk who want to start
a conversation with you.
So all the celebrities have a little bit
of a defensive mechanism--
- [Link] Well, we--
- That they're operating with.
they're operating with.
- We got there and we looked around
and we didn't see any
big-time celebrities.
And we knew they were
gonna be at this party,
so we immediately are like asking like,
is there a hidden room?
Is there like a, we let
you make a quick lap
or you're looking around and you're like,
is there like, a roped off section?
And we actually talked...
We knew the, you know, the people from GQ
who were throwing the party.
And then we were we were
talking with them and--
- We asked them point blank.
- We actually asked them--
- So where's the special...
Where's the real famous room?
- That's like, oh there isn't one.
I'm saying, okay.
- All right.
- And then I looked around and I saw Adam
from Adam Ruins Everything.
- [Rhett] Yes.
- Who we'd never met
but we both worked with
the same producing partners before and,
so we--
- He came from the internet college humor,
So we just, we kind of go
in with some confidence
thinking we probably are
familiar with each other.
- Well, I felt like we
were in similar places
on the pecking order, so anyone
could approach anyone.
He's walking by and I'm like, "hey Adam.
"I'm Link, good to meet you.
"Good to finally meet
you," is what I said,
because it's like, I
felt like we almost have
crossed paths a lot.
- That's good.
That was good.
- He was very user friendly.
He ended up talking to us for a while.
He was, you know, we were, he was familiar
with our work.
We were familiar with his work.
It was mutual adulation.
We were on the level, okay?
- Great start.
It was right when we walked in.
- We actually talked about how awkward
this place...
The exercise--
- Was.
Because he kind of explained to us--
- He's like, this isn't the first one.
- Yeah--
- With these type of
parties that I've been to.
- I don't do this normally either, right?
- So we talked about that
dynamic of pretending
to belong to then be seen as cool.
And lo and behold, as we're talking,
a photographer--
- Yeah.
- Approaches, and just
starts taking photos
of us having a candid conversation.
They were candid photos.
- Candid photos.
- And then you started talking about how
Jay-z takes a candid photo.
- Jay-z likes to laugh while
photos are taken of him.
- So, even though he's in a conversation
where it may not have been a punch line,
at the moment, he sees
the cameraman he just
kind of like, throws his head back--
- Yeah.
- And opens his mouth--
- Look at pictures--
- As if he's in mid laugh.
- Look at candid pictures of Jay-z
on the internet and you will be surprised
at how many he is smiling and laughing in.
- All of 'em.
And I immediately realized as you were
telling me and we were talking about that
dynamic with Adam Runs Everything...
The genius of it.
Because, now there's photos of Jay-z
just having the time of his life,
with other people, who apparently are
cool at parties.
So we tried that a little bit.
There may be an image floating around--
- There might be some laughing.
- Of that.
And just as a side note, Adam does
have a natural instinct
to ruin everything.
Like, as we were talking about things,
like he was like almost literally biting
his lip trying to not
overanalyze, I think in
an adorable way.
I really like the guy.
He wasn't annoying to me.
It was actually fascinating that like,
we were analyzing this party situation
and he was like breaking it down.
Like that's literally how his brain works.
- Oh of course.
Yeah, he was doing,
actually like well-informed
version of what we're
trying to do right now.
He was pointing out all the, you know,
the dynamics of the situation and seeing
right through it.
- But we knew if we kept talking to him
that we wouldn't accomplish much 'cause,
I mean, we we both felt
like we're on the same level
and we needed to make a
few laps and we're like,
if this falls apart, if we don't generate
any other leads, let's meet back here
and have a good time.
I think I said that at one point.
- So, I think I want to cover the,
sort of the first misfire, okay?
- Well, who is that?
- That's the, you know, that guy.
- Oh okay.
- I'm doing it in order.
I'm doing it order as I remember it.
- Well I did see Joe Keery before that.
The guy from Stranger Things.
- Okay.
- He was on our show.
- Yeah.
- And I went up and talked to him and he
remembered me because he was on the show.
And then his girlfriend was with him and
she is from...
I was like, I was talking
to them for a while
and I didn't know who
she was and I was like--
- It Follows.
- And I was like, and what you do?
She's like, I'm an actress.
I'm like, anything I would know?
And they were like, It Follows.
And I'm like, haven't seen that.
- Yeah, that's, so--
- So then that got, the conversation got
a little bit--
- I didn't know that
you asked that question.
But you typically, as someone who never
watches anything, you shouldn't say
anything I would know because that's
a really small pool of things.
- Well, that's her fault.
- Yeah, so you should be like, oh cool.
What are you working on now, right?
Remember, I said...
(Rhett laughing)
- Jacob almost fell out of his seat.
Yeah, that was something that we gleaned,
once we talked about this later because I
kept going to talk about what that people
were known for.
- Two lessons learned.
We already learned with
the Joe Keery conversation.
First of all, Joe was incredibly gracious
and he's like, you know, he's done this
with the way that Stranger Things
kind of blew up and now he's gotten
all these other roles like, he's like,
he's established himself.
He's a Hollywood celebrity.
He can go to these things.
Everybody recognizes him.
And he was super gracious, super nice.
His girlfriend was
equally nice and gracious.
- Yeah, we had a good time.
- Talked to us for a while.
Now, you asked me--
- And then I was like, I was feeling good.
- Well, but two things.
I want to give the two lessons learned
at this conversation.
Because the first one was, don't talk
to them about the thing
because you also talked
to Joe about how...
(Rhett laughing)
- Stranger Things season--
- No, let me say.
You told him you're like, yeah man,
I hadn't finished season two yet.
Like, so you actually, so first of all--
- Yeah and I was like,
don't spoil it for me.
But, you know what?
maybe you could spoil it for me--
- But rule number one--
- 'Cause wouldn't that
be cool if Joe Keery
spoiled season two for me?
- No it wouldn't,
because rule number one--
- No that was me talking to him.
- Rule number one is--
- I told him that.
- Okay, I wasn't there yet.
See, I didn't come in fast enough.
Rule number one is, do
not talk to a celebrity
about the thing that
they are known most for.
- Cuz every fan does that.
- Because that's what every fan does
and you're trying to establish yourself.
It's, now I'm not a
fan, I'm like you, bro.
- I'm a peer.
- So the question is--
- You were on my show.
- What are you working on now?
That's the question.
And then the second--
- That's what they want to talk about.
- A second thing that happened is,
we were up there, Stevie and I joined
the conversation.
We're talking and about, I don't know,
four minutes, four to five minutes
into the conversation, I got the sense,
I was like, we should
exit this conversation,
you know, I can kind of tell that Joe's--
- I think the proper terminology would be,
let Joe go.
- Let Joe go, because he's being gracious.
He's got lots of people to talk to.
But I don't think that
Link got that message.
And you continued to speak and continue to
bring things up.
- Yeah.
- For another five minutes.
- Really liked talking to Joe.
- Super gracious and so he wasn't gonna be
the one to bail because
he's such a nice guy.
But eventually--
- In the pecking order
you can't monopolize
someone above you--
- He did--
- Too much of their time.
- He did bail eventually.
So, the second rule is, you have to cut
the conversation, if you are...
You need to exit the conversation first
if you're below that person on the
pecking order, so that you don't seem
like you're trying to
monopolize their time.
- Yeah, it sounds ugly.
It sounds gross, but it is true.
But I was kind of riding
too high at that point.
I was like, he remembered me.
It's like, hey, we had a fun conversation.
There were laughs.
Maybe it lasted a little long, didn't
know that yet.
And then I'm walking
ahead of you guys again,
I'm like, I'm trolling
like a bass fisherman
going through, and like,
it's close quarters.
And so like, people
are passing on the left
and right, and people are, a lot of people
make eye contact because they're looking
for someone who's higher
on the pecking order
than them.
- Yep.
- People want to see somebody famous.
So I try to have a look on my face that,
like I was famous.
- Yeah, famous face.
- I had hair on my head
that looked famous.
- Yeah, yeah, we look
like guys who are trying
real hard.
I mean, the suit that I had on--
- Your suit, especially.
- Was trying so hard--
- Mine was a little toned down--
- And I'm already so tall.
I'm all ready, you know, like a beacon.
- It was like a checkerboard.
- I might as well have had like,
a light on me that was like, I'm trying
hard, you know, like a neon sign.
- I didn't have that, but I just,
I had the look on my face.
And as I walked by this couple, the guy
caught my eye and I
turn and I looked at him
at point-blank range like, yeah, I could
probably put my thumb on my nose and then
reach my pinky out and put it on his nose.
- Right, that's pretty close.
- Like, that's pretty close.
And then I was like, I recognize this guy.
I know exactly who this guy is.
And I was like, Greg!
(laughing)
- And let me just say that
his name was not Greg.
- That's not what I knew
about him, apparently.
I didn't know his name--
- But I--
- But then I followed up with me
and I was like, I could tell by the look
on his face that--
- It wasn't Greg.
- That his name was not Greg.
But--
- But, why Greg?
- I thought he looked like a Greg.
- But, that's not--
- And I was like--
- That's not how you begin conversations.
You don't look at people and imagine what
their names might be.
And then just say it.
- I knew him.
- That never should be picked.
- So I was like, uh-uh, okay your name's
not Greg but I do know who you are.
You are the rock climber.
- It was Alex Honnold.
- And I was like so, I'm sorry, just,
my name's Link.
What's your name?
He said, Alex.
I'm like, yes.
- Yeah, so--
- Your name is Alex, you climb--
- So this is where Link--
- Rock formations--
- Told him what he did.
- With no harnesses.
You are a freak of nature.
I didn't say that, but I was thinking,
your brain, your body, your everything
is a freak of nature.
He climbs like El
Capitan at Yosemite just,
in a pair of shorts and a tee shirt.
- Now, I saw you--
- And a cellphone.
- I saw you starting this conversation
and I was like, this
is a good conversation.
Like, because this is--
- Not too famous.
- This isn't somebody that everybody's
gonna know about.
This guy, he's a climber.
I follow him on Instagram.
I think he's absolutely amazing.
I do know that his name is Alex, not Greg.
- So do I, yeah.
- You know now.
And so when I saw you talking to him
I was like, this is great, go up.
I have points of
reference about who he is.
I follow him on Instagram.
And so, and again--
- I introduced you.
I remembered your name.
- Super--
- And Stevie's name.
- Super nice guy.
- Very gracious.
- And didn't act like he didn't have
time for us at all.
He was, in fact--
- I made fun of myself.
I knew that like--
- You got out of it.
You got out of it.
It's not like you completely embarrassed
yourself like later in the night.
- We fully recovered.
- Right, and he's super nice.
And he also talked about how, sure he'd,
you know, if he could be on the show
at some point.
We were like, yeah!
You know, where there's a picture of us
holding up, on Instagram, we held up
our hands because his
hands are like so like,
meaty, the kind of hands
that you need to climb
the faces of mountains, in just a pair
of shorts.
We were fascinated by...
Super nice guy.
Also, his girlfriend, super nice.
- Super nice.
I called her Ashanti.
- Yeah.
- That was not her name.
- But, by then it was a joke.
So, they're, my pet names for them,
at that point became--
- [Both] Greg and Ashanti.
- And they got a real big kick
out of that one.
I brought it back at the closer
when we were saying goodbye.
After probably talking to them for
way too long, as well.
- Definitely.
- Yeah.
It was you, also talk to them too...
You talked to them more than I did.
- But you gotta be in agreement.
I can't be like, all right Link, let's go.
I mean, like you were like, you were
so zoned in that I could, what am I gonna
be like, pinch you like
a child on the arm?
I'm not gonna do that.
- We could work something out, yeah.
- Well what we did is, right after that,
I told you, I was like, you gotta get out
of these conversations earlier.
(Link laughing)
And this is before we
established the rules.
- It's like, look at that guy in
the checkerboard suit just just giving
that other guy the third-degree.
- I was like, you're
taking these conversations
too long and it's--
- I was having a blast.
- But no, and no, to clarify cuz I know
how this, the dynamic of
this whole thing works.
The comments are gonna
be like, why is Rhett
picking on Link the way that he wants to
do the party?
I think that you also need to take some
responsibility
- Yeah, I do.
- You agree with this.
- I agree that these are lessons that--
- It became an
inconvenience for the people
that you were talking with.
- Yes.
- That's what I'm saying.
You became an inconvenience
to those people,
and you don't want to be an inconvenience
to those people.
In the same way that we wouldn't want
somebody to do that to us.
But again, at this point, no one was like,
everybody was super nice.
It wasn't like we were
ruining relationships
or anything like that.
He may be on the show.
It was so great.
I wasn't mad.
- And did you notice his eyes?
Like, his eyes were deep, dark, pools.
- He's got the eye of the tiger, man.
- It's like, you could tell
that there was something
that you normally see in people's eyes
that was not in his eyes.
- No fear.
- That allowed him to climb
a mountain with nothing.
- Not a hint of fear.
No matter what could have happened,
no matter who would have come in there,
this man cannot be afraid.
- At one point, I asked him, I was like,
"they've analyzed your brain, right?"
Because I knew there was a documentary.
He was there because there
was a documentary about him.
- That was at regular theaters.
Yeah, okay.
So, then--
- I'm still flying
pretty high at this point
in terms of, like, confidence.
- We did have a little
talk though after that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Where I was like, you know,
listen, you know, let's
not spend so much time,
but still, at this
point, to Link's credit,
I still wasn't, I didn't
say let's switch roles.
I didn't say that.
I didn't say, let me
start the conversations,
I was like, no, you still be the one
to start the conversations, Stevie and I
will come in, we'll have
a great conversation,
we'll end in a good place--
- And then we go to the--
- Let's just be a little
quicker, more efficient.
- I'm like, okay, you know, I'm teachable.
I'm open.
- It's a teachable moment.
- I want to learn, I want to make
the best of this.
So, we go to the bar, we grab us a drink,
we actually got a drink.
And then I turn around, and I was like,
that guy over there talking to that girl
that he obviously came with.
He's like, wearing a sweater.
- Yeah.
- He's got black hair.
- Dark brown.
- Dark brown, curly hair.
- Beard.
That guy is a rapper,
that guy is Lil Dicky.
- Lil Dicky.
- Lil Dicky is a very,
he's a hilarious rapper.
This is me talking to you and Stevie.
I don't know if you knew him at the time.
- Of course I knew him.
- Okay.
Skilled lyricist as well.
- Yeah.
Familiar with his work and a fan.
- So, I'm like, I'm gonna talk to him.
- And also, still, like--
- Right.
- We're not at, like, places that we will
eventually get in terms of, like,
names that everyone will know,
which is where this
conversation is going, okay?
- He's not in ubiquity.
I'm like, I'm gonna go talk to Lil Dicky.
And I guess, since I went ahead,
I should tell what happened
before we got there.
- I would love to hear you tell it.
- Just jump in when you remember
when you showed up.
Let's see.
How did this go?
I go up to him, and I'm like,
"hey, how's it going?"
- No, no, you said...
- What did I say?
- Because you told me this.
- I've told you, I just can't remember
exactly what I said.
- You said, "I would like
to introduce myself."
- Hey, man, I'd like to introduce myself,
I'm Link.
And then it was kind of
loud, there was music
playing, I was shaking his hand.
I put my head down to put my ear
towards his mouth to hear his response,
and he said, "hey, man.
"I'm," and he said--
- He said a name.
- Right.
- And then I looked up, and again, I was
just as close, I could have done
the thumb pinkie touch--
- You can't tell what
you were thinking though,
because that ruins the punchline.
- I said, "I thought you were Lil Dicky."
- And then he said.
- [Both] "I am."
(Rhett laughing)
- And I said, "well, I know,"
he was like...
"That's not, that's not my real name."
- And then he proceeded to say--
- He said Jay-Z, he brought up Jay-Z.
He said--
- I was there by this point.
- He said, "Jay-Z's name is not Jay-Z."
And I was like, "well, I know that.
"I was just...
"I mean, I understand that's not
"your name, but I just didn't
"know if it was you."
Because here's what happened,
it wasn't that I thought
his name was Lil Dicky
and he was gonna introduce
himself that way.
It's that, when I got that close
to Lil Dicky for the very first time
in my life, and, like, I'm looking up
and I could have, you know, I could have,
I could have kissed him on the nose.
When I was that close, I immediately
was overwhelmed with the thought,
this is not Lil Dicky.
This is just some guy.
- Oh gosh.
Some guy that looks a lot
like Lil Dicky at the GQ party.
- But again, when you get that close
to somebody, you can see the pores
in their skin.
- You've never seen that.
- You start to--
- You've never seen Lil Dicky in 4K.
- They look a little more real
than any other way they've been
presented on any screen.
And so, at that moment,
I was just thinking,
I don't want to have a conversation
with this guy thinking he's Lil Dicky,
but it turns out he's not.
I don't want to invest
that amount of time,
because that's gonna get awkward.
So, instead of making this awkward,
having an awkward conversation as if
I think he's a rapper that he's not--
- I'm gonna make it more awkward
than I ever could possibly,
other than that first scenario.
- I'm just gonna say, I thought
you were Lil Dicky.
I am.
- Which, you realize that in avoiding
awkwardness, you stepped into
one of the most awkward
conversations you had.
Probably the most awkward conversation
you had that night.
- In my time on the planet.
Because it didn't end there.
Because then I was, like, trying to,
I was like, oh, here's my friends,
Rhett and Stevie.
Hopefully they can help
rescue me from this awkward
moment I've created.
Again, I thought, I'll just acknowledge
that I've done this.
And then at that point, he turned to me
and he said, "you're doing great."
(Rhett laughing)
Which, side note, if you ever hear that
in the conversation, it doesn't mean
you're doing great.
And I'm not, I'm just
saying what happened.
I'm not trying to paint Lil Dicky
as a lil dicky or a big dicky.
- Here's the deal, I'll
say that I actually
think he's a very nice guy.
- I think he was trying his best.
- I think he was trying to make it funny,
because what was happening was so awkward,
I think he was just
trying to make it funny.
And you know what?
- Me too.
- It was very funny.
- It was funny.
And you know what?
He deserves no hate for that response.
Because I don't think he was being mean,
I think he was trying to play it off.
- Yeah, he was.
- And it was funny from his perspective.
- But we talked about,
okay, so, there's a lot
of lessons learned in this situation.
I mean, obviously--
- Well, it got worse after that,
because I was talking to him, I was like,
you talked to him a little bit.
You and Stevie were kind
of embarrassed for me,
and I get that.
And then I was like, hey, man,
your songs are hilarious.
They actually played one of them in my--
- Oh gosh.
- In my gym.
- I forgot about this.
- Like, they were playing one in the gym,
and I was just, like,
busting out laughing.
And I was like--
- You were violating
that other rule again.
- Yeah, I talked about--
- You were talking about your personal,
your very personal touch point.
- I was fanboying over his song,
and then I was like, I was like,
"yeah, man, I'm in there laughing."
I'm like, "you're helping me get fit.
"Like, this," and then
I pointed at my body,
"this is for you."
- Yeah.
- I was like, "no, I don't mean,
"I don't mean this is for you, I meant,
"this is because of you.
"Like, me being this fit is because,
"I was just trying to make a joke
"that they played your song in my gym."
- Here's the thing--
- "But this is for you if you want it."
- At this point, at this point,
Lil Dicky should have said,
you know what, I'm not Lil Dicky.
That's actually what he should have said,
because it would have
ended the conversation.
- And it's interesting, because,
do you remember?
A guy came over my left shoulder and said,
hey, man, and he leaned into his ear
and he was like, I really
blah blah blah blah blah.
And then Lil Dicky was like, thanks, man.
And then the guy walked off.
And then I said to him, I was like--
- That's what I should have done.
- Now, that's what I should have done.
I told him that.
But there was no recovering.
I was like a puddle.
- Well, okay, but there's a couple things.
Because we gotta get to more stuff.
There's better stories than this,
believe it or not.
- That's it, I'm done.
- The first thing that I said is--
- I'm still a fan.
- I don't think that you should say
I would like--
- [Both] To introduce myself.
- My name is Link.
Because, I think that you should just,
I'm not saying you shouldn't
introduce yourself,
but you began the conversation in a way
that was like, I know
that you have no idea
who I am and I'm just coming at you
from this just, I'm just a fan,
versus just like, hey, I'm Link.
You could have just said, hey, I'm Link.
- Give him a little bit, a sliver of doubt
that they might know who you are
or have worked with you are before,
or should know who you are.
- I personally like to
go with good to see you.
Because that's not untrue.
- Not again, but just, good to see you.
- Good to see you.
- But then you, and
then you say, I'm Rhett?
You can't do both of those.
- I'm reading, I'm reading the situation.
But in these situations, I came in so late
that it was just--
- But it was the plan.
- And then it was just,
we were just talking
about what you had talked about.
So, and again, you already know
the whole thing about, like, if you think
somebody's that person,
then just go with it
until you find another way
out of the conversation
other than suddenly doubting
in the middle of conversation.
- Jay-Z's name is not
Jay-Z as it turns out.
- So, after that happened, we began
to talk about how, what we had done
is, we created an incredible Ear Biscuit.
It was like, the stories
that were being generated
by your interactions with people
were so entertaining to me that
I was just having a great time,
Stevie and I both, being blown away
at how South the conversations were going.
- Well, we talked to
Bo Burnham after that,
and that was a great
conversation because--
- It was.
- We reminisced about the first time
we met in 2008.
- Yeah, YouTube life.
- Had a good little conversation.
Saw him later, made eye contact,
and then we went in different directions
because we had already
had our conversation.
- Right.
But then we're rolling around the party,
and one of the things,
this is another sort of
principal that you see in these
industry parties, is that the recognizable
faces begin to thin out
very quickly, right?
After, you know, I
don't know, if the party
starts at 9:00 o'clock, well,
then by 10:30 at the latest,
anybody that you would recognize
as a celebrity, they're gone.
And now it's just the industry people
who just want to have
a party who are there.
- They got in their one
picture and they're out.
- Again, we do not see
ourselves as celebrities.
We, we're at the party
to kind of establish
ourselves in that way, but that's not how
we think about ourselves, and so we have
to have this thing where it's like,
it kicks in, and we're
like, ah, you know what?
Anybody else who's supposed to be famous
has left, so we should probably leave too.
Like, it's literally
that level of reasoning.
It's not cool in any way.
Let's get one more
drink, or let's get some
more of that food.
I want another one of those cake pops.
You know me, I'm going for the food.
- And as we're contemplating
that, there's like,
a line of people.
And I turn around, I
look over my shoulder,
Michael B. Jordan is walking by.
And I'm like, he's in motion.
he's going towards the exit.
If I'm gonna meet Michael B. Jordan,
or if you're gonna meet
him, this is the moment.
So, I wheeled around.
And I was like, "hey, I'd
like to introduce myself.
"I'm Link."
I hadn't gotten over that yet.
And he was like, "hey, man."
- He never stopped, by the way,
I watched this happen.
- He never stopped moving.
- Which is smart.
- And as I rotated, trying
to follow Michael B. Jordan,
muscular dude, shorter than me though.
(Rhett laughing)
He said, he was like, I was like,
"congratulations on everything."
- Yeah, that wasn't bad,
that was pretty good.
It's a good line.
- Then he kept moving, and
as I turned back around
to look at you guys, I got hit
in the shoulder by a guy--
- Bodyguard number one.
- Who was following Michael B. Jordan.
And then I continued to turn around,
I got hit in the shoulder
by another guy's shoulder.
- Bodyguard number two.
Yeah.
- And then, if my memory
serves me correctly--
- I saw it happen four times.
- There was at least two more guys.
- I saw you get hit four times.
- Who felt the need to
make physical contact
with my shoulder just to let me know,
hey, dude, you just talked to my employer
as he was exiting, and
I just want my presence
to be felt, and that happened four times
in rapid succession.
It didn't hurt, it wasn't aggressive,
it wasn't physical.
- It was just kind of establishing--
- I'm not gonna press any charges.
- The way things work, it's
just the way things work.
- Yeah, he had some bodyguards.
I don't think anybody
else there had bodyguards.
- But then, right before we leave,
we're like, we gotta make one last,
is there a section of the party
that we missed?
Because, again, we're looking--
- Let's make one more round.
- I mean, I'm looking at, like,
the previous year's
pictures from this party,
and, like, Rihanna was there.
And of course, I'm thinking,
if I meet Rihanna, I gotta talk to her
about how, you know, I have a crush
on you on the internet.
- I think you might, would have
had to introduce yourself.
- Yeah.
I would have said, I would
like to introduce myself.
And I wouldn't have cared how it went.
But we're thinking, we're
gonna meet somebody like that.
And so, we take one last little stroll,
and there's this little area outside
that we hadn't seen yet, and it was,
I think it was, like, the smoking section.
- It was a porch.
Stevie was like, oh,
there's a porch out there.
And then she grabs my arm.
She was like, "it's not a secret section,
"it's been the smoking section all along.
"All the coolest celebrities
"are in the smoking section."
Which, don't smoke, celebrities.
It's not good for you.
- And not everybody was smoking
in the smoking section, it was just,
it's what it was.
- It was small.
We walked out there, and of course
it was dwindling by this point,
and I didn't see anybody,
and we're standing out there,
then all of a sudden.
(gasps)
- John Mayer.
Now--
- We're 40 year old white guys.
- [Rhett] I think it's important--
- So, we like John Mayer.
- I think it's important for me
to tell this one from my perspective.
- There are people who hate John Mayer,
so if we're talking about how we're, like,
gushing over John Mayer,
they'll be like, what,
you're in poor taste
or something, I don't know.
- Let's just set record straight
about John Mayer.
His most recent albums, when he went
a little bit country,
that is his best work.
If you disagree with that, you're wrong.
He's an incredible musician,
he's an incredible song writer,
he's an incredible lyricist,
he's an incredible guitar player.
Like, virtuoso guitar player.
Now, he may have made some weird
personal choices and
statements in the past,
and I'm not defending that, and I'm not
even referencing that, but he is
an incredible musician, and we both
love his music, and so this was
an important moment for us
when we saw John Mayer.
- So, we're standing, you know,
I could probably throw a rock
hard enough to kill
him from that distance.
(Rhett laughing)
I don't know, I'm just trying to,
I don't want to do that,
I'm just trying to--
- I love the way that you--
- Trying to say distance.
- You like to paint the
physical space picture.
I was close enough that if I was
talking to him and had
my finger on my nose.
- Right, if I had a rock
about the size of a fist, I could
probably kill him with it.
- But based on the way that you had
behaved throughout the night.
At this point, I wasn't even having to do,
Stevie was in charge at this point.
And she said, you cannot talk to him.
You cannot talk to John Mayer, okay?
And we were--
- And I'm like, you know what?
Yeah, you're right, I'm
not gonna talk to him.
- And he was standing next to,
the three of us were in our little group,
and he was in a group of, like,
two or three people talking to them.
And we were, you know, close enough
to kill him with a rock.
And at that point, we're saying,
Link, you can't talk to him because
it's just gonna be super awkward.
But then he begins to leave,
and that exit involves walking past us.
- Walking behind me.
- And actually closest to you.
So, you did the Michael B. Jordan move,
and you turned.
- Well, yeah, and I've been saying,
I'm not gonna, I'll play nice,
I'm not gonna, we'll wait
for another opportunity.
There's be another time
to meet John Mayer.
I'm not gonna, I gotta gather myself,
there'll be another party.
But then when he started exiting,
and he was right behind me, I was like,
ah, sike.
I gotta meet him.
And so I wheeled around.
- And you said, "hey, John."
What was you middle statement?
Because it was your last statement that,
you were like...
Congrats?
- I think I was like, big fan.
- You said something that
wasn't as specific as big fan.
And I told the story to a bunch of people,
and I can't remember,
but the last part was--
- And then he kept, he
didn't stop walking.
He was like, "hey, man, yeah, thanks."
And he was exiting.
- But you said, "I love you."
(Rhett laughing)
- Yeah, I did.
I told him that I loved him.
- And you didn't intend that.
- No.
- You could tell by
the way you started it,
it was, I love you.
It changed into I love you.
- Right.
I, I love.
Well, he was walking away so fast.
- No, no, you said, "hey, John.
"Nice work.
"I love you."
- Yeah, that was it.
- That is exactly what
you said to John Mayer.
- "Hey, John, nice work."
He said, "thanks, man, thanks."
He kept walking, I'm like, "I love you."
(Rhett laughing)
And then he was gone.
But from my perspective, from, like,
inside of my brain, which, you know--
- It's a weird place.
- You should buy a ticket.
Uh, it's worth the wait.
I think I was gonna say something like,
I love your work.
But he was gone, so it was just,
I love your, your.
- No, you said I love you.
- Well, I was facing him, not you.
- You're trying to save it.
You said I love you.
- But you know what, I do love him.
- And that's great.
And you know what?
John doesn't care.
He doesn't remember you.
- No.
It wasn't a memorable exchange.
Now, Lil Dicky, I think might remember me.
- Yeah, he probably does.
- I feel the need to take a moment
to speak directly to--
- He's probably told that story.
- What is his name?
- His name is David.
- Dave.
- David Burd.
- He introduced himself as Dave.
Dave, I know your name's not Lil Dicky.
I know that I put you
in an awkward position,
and I even know that in telling our story
that it might paint you as the guy,
but I want to go on record and say
that you did the best you could,
you even brought some humor into it,
which I fully appreciate.
I'm still a fan.
You didn't do anything wrong.
So, you have no need to apologize,
and no need for me to let you off
the hook even though I'm doing it.
I look forward to seeing you again
where we can have a normal conversation,
and let's just go from there.
Can we start over?
Can I have a do over?
- Sure.
- Thanks, Dave.
And John.
Just have a moment with you.
- He's not watching.
- I love you.
- There's not a chance.
- That's it, that's all
I wanted to say to you.
- So, as we, so, on the
way home that night,
we started kind of establishing--
- John's got a big noggin.
- Well, all the greats do.
All the greats do, all
the great songwriters--
- Up close like that?
- Have big heads.
- His head's like twice as big as yours.
- No, it's not twice as big,
it's probably 20% bigger.
- Yeah.
In a good way.
- As we discussed the rules, we've kind
of been through a few of them,
get out of the conversation earlier,
don't talk about, don't talk about
the thing that they're known for.
Talk about some tangential or just ask,
what are you working on now?
Don't assume that they don't know who
you are, just talking to them like you're
picking up a conversation.
Don't tell them that you love them.
- Don't be a fanboy.
- And there's a certain
level of celebrity,
and I think Michael B. Jordan
and John Mayer both fit this bill,
that there's just really no circumstances
that you should talk to them.
There's very few, I
think there's very few--
- I can't accept that.
- There's very few to that conversation
going the way that you would want.
I think it's typically gonna be,
you're gonna be talking to somebody
who then has a connection
or something like that.
Now, you're gonna get more of a thrill,
and you're gonna get better stories.
- I think Mamrie Hart
met Reese Witherspoon
at a party and they're like
best friends now.
She's so much better with people.
- Well, that's for sure.
- I think we need to
hire her to consult me.
- But--
- I'm just gonna go to
the parties with Mamrie.
- But, again--
- Of course, I kind of need to be invited.
- Again, I'm grateful, I'm grateful
that you took the initiative.
I'm grateful that we have these stories.
These stories are probably,
in one sentence, more strategic
and of more value than the relationship
that we could have had with those people,
that we will never have
with those people now.
But you know what?
We may, Alex Honnold might
be on the show at some point.
- Don't forget, we talked to Terry Crews.
He knew who we are, and he gave us
a motivational speech that same night.
- And let me say, I initiated
the conversation with Terry Crews.
- That's 'cause we had seen
him the night before.
- That's what I'm saying.
I'm outlining the differences.
And I'm not saying, I think
that in the setting, you--
- I talked to Terry.
- You're better at these things.
So, what I'm saying is, I will talk
to anybody if I got a point of contact.
And so, we had seen him at the,
he's, by the way, we talked about
this before, nicest guy on the planet.
Terry Crews, nicest guy on the planet.
And actually, he and
his son watch the show,
it was incredible.
But we took these rules,
and we said, the next time we go
to a party, we're going to apply
some of these rules.
And so, we got invited to the...
HBO Golden Globes after party.
And I was coming back from,
first of all, it was, you know,
we were told, I think you probably could,
you didn't have to have a tux,
but technically black tie.
We didn't have tuxes.
I was in Mexico at the time,
and I was gonna have to get back,
get fitted for a tux,
because the Rhettster
don't wear something off the rack
because they don't make
things that fit me, okay?
So, I have to get things fitted,
I have to get things tailored
if they're gonna look halfway decent.
So, I was gonna have to get off the plane,
come here to the office, get fitted
for a tux, and them immediately
get into a car and go to this party,
which is what happened.
And I was actually a little bit late
because there was a flight delay.
So, we're going down, and apparently all
the parties after the Golden Globes
are at the hotel, the Beverley Hilton
where the Golden Globes are held.
And they're all in these little areas,
so you got Netflix and Amazon and Hulu
or whatever, and HBO.
So, there's like six parties.
Like, big, significant parties,
and they're all in the same place,
and so, because the traffic would be
so crazy to this little hotel,
they have a shuttle service where you
meet offsite at a parking area,
and you get into these shuttles.
- And we were told to Uber to
the location of the
shuttles, then a shuttle
will take you to the party,
and then, you know, bring your ID
so you can, you know.
- Because there's a list.
- There's a list.
- Right.
So, we get to the shuttle area, and we see
just a bunch of shuttles lined up,
and we go to the first one,
and it's closed, and it's full.
We go to the second one, it's closed,
and it's full.
We go to the third one, the door's open.
What do we do?
We go on the shuttle.
- Yeah, I go up in the shuttle.
And lo and behold, the shuttle's full
except for two seats.
(angelic singing)
- How many of us are there?
- Two.
Perfect math.
- Just the two of us.
- So we sat down.
- We sit down, and then we begin
to have a conversation with a woman
who's sitting next to us.
And this conversation concerns
me a little bit, you know,
as the one who tends to worry
a little bit more and try to figure
out if we're doing the right thing.
- Yeah, I was feeling great.
- You were just like,
we're on the shuttle,
we're on the shuttle, it's great.
- And I was like, but something doesn't
seem right about this, because we didn't
talk to anybody, we
just got on the shuttle,
and then we talked, and the woman
was not going to the HBO party.
I think she was already under
the influence of something.
- Okay.
- There was something going on there
because it was not clear
communication from her.
I didn't want to seem uncool, but I was
just like, is this going to the HBO party?
And she was like, "well, it
goes to all the parties."
And then I'm like, "what do you mean?
"Are we gonna be dropped
off at different parties?"
We didn't know that all the parties
were at the same place.
We knew nothing.
I'm beginning to think we should
get off of the shuttle and tell people,
hey, we want to go to the HBO party.
- We don't belong here is what
it sounded like to me, so I'm like,
nope, staying put on the shuttle.
I'm not gonna admit defeat in front
of everybody on this shuttle
by having a walk of shame.
- Stay tuned to what actually happened.
- Walk of shame.
And then the shuttle starts
moving, so we don't--
- Too late at that point.
- We're, like, arguing with each other
under our breath, and I'm
trying to calm Rhett down.
And then it's like, well,
the shuttle's moving.
There's nothing we can do now.
We finally get over there
to the Beverley Hilton--
- Which was like, half a mile away,
it wasn't even that far.
- They let us off, and then they're like,
a lot of security people
on the red carpet there,
and they're like wrist bands, wrist bands.
And I'm like, wrist bands?
I ain't heard nothing
about no wrist bands.
- And everyone on the
shuttle has a wrist band
except you know who, the two guys
that just walked onto the shuttle
randomly, because
apparently there was a whole
thing at the parking place where you had
to get checked in and get your wrist
band so you could get into the hotel.
- There were no signs,
there was no orientation.
- Yeah, in our defense,
no one told us this.
- And there was other
people who were like,
oh, we Ubered directly here
because I didn't want
to get on that shuttle,
and I don't have a wrist band either,
so this woman's, like, taking down names
and going, she's with HBO and she's
going to get wrist bands.
- Okay, now, at this point, talk about
being a little bit embarrassed,
if you're talking about
trying to save face
for the shuttle, what
ended up happening is,
everyone's getting off these shuttles
and just walking straight past security,
and you and I and some real estate people,
they said that they were real estate,
are all standing out there.
- Like fans.
- Yeah.
Not able to get in.
And we look like two
guys that just dressed
up and walked, and we're
just hoping we could
slide by security like the Grammy video
we did years ago.
- Because that does happen.
There are people lurking and trying
to look like they belong, and just get in.
Jeff Bridges was leaving.
- All kinds of people
were coming and going.
All kinds of very recognizable actors.
- My favorite actor--
- Stephen Root walked behind you.
- I know.
And then you didn't tell me until
he was already gone.
- Because I didn't want
you, and you should
thank me for this.
I didn't want you to meet your favorite
character actor, Stephen Root--
- On the outside of a party where it--
- Without a wrist band.
- Yeah.
- You didn't want to do that either.
- Nope.
- So, thank me.
- I'm not ready to do
that, because he wasn't
in the party, Rhett.
He wasn't in our party.
- Yeah, but he would have
been like, you coming?
And you would have been like,
as soon as I get a wrist band.
And he would have been like, oh,
he's one of those guys.
But we may have ended up fairing better
than if we hadn't gotten on the shuttle.
- I think we did.
- Because it did take about 30 minutes of,
I was kind of frantically our PR people,
because I thought that we were not gonna
get in at that point, we were
gonna have to go back to home base and it
was gonna set us back forever.
But eventually, we did get,
somebody came out and gave us wrist bands,
and then we were able to check in.
It did take about 30
minutes, and a lot of people
walking by.
But we have reason to believe that if
we had have gone all the way to the
back of the line and
checked in the right way,
we probably would have gotten
to the party like an
hour and a half later.
It was ridiculous how late this thing was.
But then we go in.
- So, we got in earlier.
- But we got in, and, uh,
this party was different.
It was bigger.
- You could get plates
full of food at this party,
and there were seats.
There were tables, like round tables.
It was much more laid back.
It was more like a dinner party.
Well, not a dinner party, but a party
where you could eat dinner.
(Link laughing)
- Yeah, a party where you can eat dinner.
- But not a dinner party where everybody's
seated and someone gives a speech,
that's not it.
- But I would say the percentage of--
- Really famous people was--
- Lower percentage of
really famous people,
but a lot of, like, I know that guy
from that movie, I know that guy
from that show, but I don't know his name,
and you probably wouldn't either,
but you'd recognize him.
It was a lot of those people and then
a lot of industry people.
And it was a much larger party
in terms of space and
in terms of attendance.
- We had some good
conversations with people who,
you know, again, it's good to have
industry conversations, meet producers
and all this type of stuff.
So, it's like, and a number of those
people talked to us because
they knew who we were.
Sometimes because their
kids know who we were,
but hey, that's a good in.
I'll take it any way I can get it.
And we also, well, we had a couple
people that we wanted to talk to, right?
It's a HBO party, so we thought that
Mark and Jay Duplass
would be there, right?
We both finished reading their book.
- Yup.
- Fans of theirs.
We think--
- I'd like to have a
conversation with them.
- We'd like to talk to those guys.
Because we just think that--
- Just relate to their relationship.
- Similar backgrounds
and similar philosophies,
but they weren't there.
They could have been there,
and maybe we missed them,
but we didn't see them.
Because I was trying
to, and maybe I pushed
it too far in my direction, which,
I was like, let's talk to people
that we've got a reason to talk to.
That doesn't mean we have to know them,
but, like, let's initiate a conversation
and there's, like, an in.
With those guys, it would have been like,
hey, we just read your book.
And first of all, that
would mean something
to them because we're not talking
about Room 104 or whatever everybody
else is talking about.
We're talking about
this thing that, like--
- Pet project.
- You guys like the book?
Yeah, we just listened to it,
here's all these parallels
that are really interesting
between us and you guys.
- You were prepped for that.
- I was ready for that conversation.
But that didn't happen.
We saw Pete Holmes, who had been
on Good Mythical Morning.
- Let's call him a friend of the show.
- Friend of the show.
And had a conversation, met his wife
for the first time, had
a great conversation
with Pete.
He actually said basically the same thing,
he was like, "it took us forever
"to get into this party,
and I'm glad I ran
"into you guys, because
having a conversation
"I want to be in makes it worth it."
That felt great.
You know, 'cause he's
thinking the same thing.
He's got a show on HBO and he's thinking
the same thing.
Like, who am I gonna
talk to at this thing.
- But let's not make it out to be like,
we have to have certain
types of interactions
at a party to feel good about ourselves.
Because earlier, you established
that we don't need that.
- Well, but I'm not the one that tries to,
well, then what is your goal in all
the conversations that
you try to initiate?
You're just trying to have a good time?
- Move and shake.
I mean, there is a business to this,
but it's not, it's what, I don't need
to feel good about myself.
And I don't think you do either,
but I'm just saying that it sounded
like it in that moment where it's like,
oh, it felt good for somebody to say
they wanted to talk to us.
And it did feel good.
But it's just a weird, it's a weird
environment where, like, and maybe
this is kind of true of LA in general,
is that it's people trying to
get themselves noticed or get their
project accomplished.
Or to make their way.
And so, it's, you know, industry parties
are industry parties.
They're to work.
You know, it's not like a friend party,
like you said, where, like,
yeah, there may be a bunch of celebrities
at a party, and boy,
wouldn't that be interesting,
but they're there because they're friends.
That's' not an industry party.
- Well, because, I mean--
- Gotta get something done.
- Well, because one of the things
that we're thinking about,
just strategically, creatively,
I don't know, one of the
things that we've learned
is getting really qualified people
to help you make things happen
is, that's what we want to do, right?
I mean, that's the reason that we're doing
what we do today, is
because at some point,
we figured out, oh, you
know what really works?
Is getting people who can do things better
than we can to do those things.
And that's why we have a team now.
But the same thing applies to,
who are you gonna work with?
Who are you gonna collaborate with
on this project?
Who's gonna help write it, produce it,
who's gonna act in it?
That kind of thing, and things
that we want to do.
And so, you want to have those connections
so that, when you say, here's the idea,
will you help make it happen?
Would you like to be in it, to an actor
or whatever, it's like, oh, yeah,
I do, because either I saw you
at that party and I saw you guys
on the red carpet, and then I looked,
you know, these little touch points matter
if you want to play that game.
- But it's all unspoken.
I don't think, well,
maybe there is a booklet
or something, but, and
maybe I could have saved
a lot of heartache, and sidestepped
a fun podcast though, by reading it.
- I don't think that any
damage has been done.
- No.
- Let me just clarify that--
- I didn't say it had been.
- I think that even the most
embarrassing interaction that you had
with Mr. David Burd, Lil Dicky,
is what they call him.
He has a rap name.
- I call him Dave.
- Even that conversation, the chances
of us working with Lil Dicky
actually went up because
of the interaction.
Now, there are interactions where
the chances would have gone down, right?
The chances would have gone down,
they were at a tipping,
they were right there
in a real gray area for a second there.
- Glad I didn't have a
rock with John Mayer.
That would have been horrible.
- But I do think that
the most important thing
is just beginning the conversation,
but I do think that we now know
how to be a tad more strategic.
- I think that there were no mishaps
at the Golden Globe party,
except for the shuttle thing,
which I think ended up being great.
We got there early.
So, I don't think I have any demerits.
- No, lessons learned at Golden Globes.
- At the HBO party.
- Yeah, I can't think of any
lessons learned at the
Golden Globes party.
- And I got a tux out of it.
Well, I mean, I bought it.
- Well, I'll tell you
one lesson we learned,
we actually applied it.
After you go through the red carpet
and get your pictures
taken by the professional
photographers, you go
back to the red carpet
at the end of the night,
and there will be people
taking their picture with their iPhones.
You get one of them to take a picture
of you with your phone, and
that will allow you to have a picture on
your camera roll that isn't,
you don't have to wait until
the next day to get some Getty image
or something like that.
- That's right.
- So, the picture that we posted
was just a picture from the phone.
That's a little hack.
That's a little insider tip.
- There it is.
So, we're gonna, so, now,
next time we post photos
from the next thing we go to,
you're gonna be thinking, man,
that's a lot more complicated
than I thought it was.
Lots of ins and outs.
- Yeah.
- So, thanks for hanging out with us.
Thanks for learning along with us.
Because, I mean, let's be clear.
We both learned a lot, right?
- I learned so much watching you.
(Link laughing)
So much.
- Yeah, I'm a...
I'm a teacher, man, I'm
a teacher in action.
What not to do.
- Yeah, you teach by example.
You teach by bad examples.
(Link laughing)
It is a form of teaching.
I admit it.
It is fun.
I'm enjoying myself, and Stephen Root,
I'm coming for you.
- [Rhett] Oh gosh.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous episode
of Ear Biscuits, click on
the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(soft music)